thank you a tough opening act to follow
i also want to just point out that some
of you have seen me give it talk many
years back on a related topic this is
not this is not old wine in a new bottle
its new wine in an old bottle in the
sense that i've got the same model but
hopefully have some newer results that i
thought were worth mentioning so just to
get started I really you know myosin has
been invoked enough times today and over
the week that I shouldn't need to invoke
him again but this is being recorded for
posterity so I might as well go through
this once basic question how should a
seller of a good auction it off and we
have at least one nice answer that we
keep return returning to which is if
there's a monopoly seller and he has n
buyers and these buyers are iid from a
known distribution and everyone that
there's common knowledge of this
distribution and the seller wants to
maximize expected revenue then the
problem is really nice well it's
actually really nice in one case so
what's that case that case is when the
virtual value of a buyer is
non-decreasing in his actual value and
then myosin tells you that the optimal
auction is second price auction with the
reserve that's easy enough to calculate
the other case which we show under the
metaphorical carpet very often is the
case where that assumption is not
satisfied we help our case along by
calling these regular distributions and
these irregular distributions but the
basic point is that the optimal auction
that comes out to the extent that you
believe the math is weird it involves
something called ironing it may miss
allocate the good by that I mean that
the optimal auction in this case may
sometimes give the good to a buyer of a
lower value even though a buyer of a
higher value is present and in the
auction so that sort of thing can happen
and that should be troubling all the way
off at the other end of the spectrum
there's another canonical paper that
doesn't come up hasn't come up as much
this week so what's that paper it's by
mcafee and McAfee considers a large
market so by a large market we mean many
cell
us with each with a single item many
buyers and all of these buyers are sort
of I I'd have values I ID from a known
distribution and the game he's thinking
about is that each of these sellers is
going to announce an option each of the
bias is then going to choose which
sellers auction to visit and the each
buyer is going to choose this after
knowing both her own value and all the
announcements of all the sellers and
mcafee result is that given everyone
else and well I mean I've stated it as a
best response he states it as an
equilibrium but what's the best response
of mapping that he particularly points
out he says given that everybody else
has announced a second price auction
with no reserve any given sellers best
response is to also announce a second
price auction with no reserve now part 1
this means of course it's an equilibrium
for everyone to announce second price
options with no reserve part two is that
mcafee doesn't make any assumptions on
the distribution of x 0 values so the
thing that was driving the distinction
between sort of standard second price
options and weird things in myosin is
missing in McAfee so of course you know
you're a young grad student or your
young assistant professor what do you do
you look to fill a much needed gap in
the literature so you ask what would
what should we expect any monopoly so
here's here's the most obvious model you
could write down there's a cellar with a
single unit of a good to sell there's M
minus one other sellers so totally M
sellers in the market and they also have
a single unit of the same good there's
two buyers we can talk offline about how
to extend it past to that some of the
results will extend some parts that I
hope to be able to prove actually don't
extend so they're all iid the other
sellers have committed to a second price
auction with no reserve ok so just all I
want to do is to identify one part of
the best response mapping which is how
should our distinguished seller seller
one respond to a second price auction
with no reserve and
I'm going to do is I'm just going to try
and repeat the Maya Sonia an exercise in
this setting and try to understand
what's going on the game is going to be
like mcafee switch is each buyer is
going to choose which seller to visit
after this bio knows after each buyer
the buyer knows both her own value and
all the announce mechanisms so we're
going to look at an equilibrium in the
sub game among buyers that is defined by
the mechanism that was announced by me
by this distinguished seller all the
buyers move simultaneously yeah and the
difficulty is of course that you don't
have a nice linear program anymore the
optimal auction must design must account
for how this incentivizes for how the
design of the auction incentivizes
buyers to visit and of course before you
think this is just an optimal auction
design problem with a fixed outside
option note that the distribution of
buyers visiting the other auctions
depend on which ones are visiting me
which means that the outside options
that the buyers have that is what they
would get if they went to another option
also depends on the different design of
my options so everything is sort of
endogenously determined which makes it
are tricky the main result i'm going to
present today is distant recompile
correctly for a seller competing against
M minus 1 other sellers who have each
announced second price auction with no
reserve necessary conditions for a
second price auction possibly with some
reserves to be optimal are that this
term over here this thing over here this
modified virtual value is increasing in
V now note that this is sort of
convenient in the sense that when M
equals one that is I don't have any
competition i get back myosin and when M
equals infinity the second term
basically disappears and I get back
mcafee to footnotes that I should do
caveat first I want to emphasize so that
I don't over-promised and
under-delivered the word necessary I
don't have sufficient conditions
this point what I'm doing as you will
see in a minute is basically writing
down a particularly Harry nonlinear
optimization problem and can using the
necessary conditions there to get
necessary conditions here what I don't
have yet is sufficient conditions but
the only the sufficient conditions for
this class of nonlinear program problems
don't apply so what I am in the process
this is very much work in progress what
I'm trying to do is use the same
necessary conditions to rule out all
other auctions but all other mechanisms
but that's a slightly more involved
exercise that we can talk about how far
I got offline do you conjecture that
this is necessary you actually a counter
examples no i do not have counter
examples i conjecture conjecture is such
a strong word in I hope it i hope it's
necessary and sufficient is you know i
mean things when once you say conjecture
it almost you know becomes yes Costas I
mean second price with reserve so my
best response could include a second
price with the reserve but I'm fixing
all the other competitors competing
sellers to announce zero reserve price
auction so I want okay so every why do i
need this well because you know think
about it if I didn't fix the reserve
they might be how my other sellers might
have a reserve price so high that
they're not really competing at all so I
want to make the environment as
competitive as possible they're
announcing second price with no reserve
and all I'm doing is I'm trying to I'm
trying to make this I'm trying to figure
out my best response with the result yes
yes sorry everything should be am sorry
that was that was a typo that oh yes I
know you're not conjecturing anything
natural result is when the sake is set
to zero or you know that's not the case
you know no what's embarrassed sorry so
k equals 1 the reserve is exactly where
this equals 0 yeah yeah so
embarrassingly I was asked this question
and I still haven't figured it out so I
I don't have a it I just don't know I'm
sorry so that's that's the result and if
I had to give a grandiose a grandiose
overview of why you should care it's
that in a world where these are if these
conditions are indeed the right ones
then basically the set of distributions
on which you do weird things that is
things other than second price auction
'he's shrinks as competition grows large
so competition sort of takes away
complexity you know in a particularly
complex world so that's that's that's a
grandiose one sentence whatever what's
the high level intuition high level
intuition let's let's go through two
things we again know really well so
first think of a world where they're a
bunch of buyers but it's a full
information setting so these buyers come
stamped with their values on their
foreheads okay that's a really simple
setting to optimize revenue you just
find the highest value guy you give him
the good and you charge him his value
okay that's trivial now in the myosin
monopoly setting the setting with
private information the seller doesn't
know biases values by the revelation
principle he can just ask people for
their values but then of course the
mechanism has to be incentive compatible
incentive compatibility means that
roughly speaking allocating a low value
buyer leaves rents for higher value
buyers you have to give people money to
tell the truth right you have to leave
some money on the table to get them to
tell the truth because unlike here you
don't know what their values are the
virtual value which we've all come to
know and love and everyone or almost
everyone in this room is played around
with at some point captures this cost of
incentive compatibility that is it
captures the a value less a shadow cost
of inset of these incentive
compatibility constraints and the
monopoly distortions of the
because the seller would like to give
the good to the largest virtual value
rather than give the good to the buyer
with the highest value okay and when
this sort of thing is non-monotonic
that's when you get the weird ironing
stuff that myosin talks about so far so
good the basic observation that I'm
making here is that when you have
competition you have outside options
outside options I'm claiming reduce the
shadow cost of incentive constraints
intuitively to get people to show up
you'd have to offer those rents to them
anyway so you shouldn't double count
okay so roughly what you'll now have is
the old virtual value plus some
correction for the fact that you need to
convince these guys to show up now
firstly this term is positive so you had
V minus something plus something so this
thing holy is less negative so it's
closer to true value what a lot of
analysis that have existing analysis
that I've seen tends to do sometimes
justified sometimes not is including
what I did in my in the previous
incarnation of this work is basically
say if you don't think too good don't
think too hard so we want we would
roughly want this whole thing to be
increasing so well one thing we can do
is hope for this thing to be increasing
and this thing to be increasing right
make this thing increasing you say
increasing virtual values to make this
thing increasing you say decreasing
density what I'm trying to claim today
is that actually no that's overkill the
structure of the competing options
problem lets us say a little bit about
the nature of these these outside option
the lagrangians of the outside option
constraints and that's going to help us
get slightly tighter results than we had
previously
oh yes what you saying if both of those
terms are increasing I'm saying if those
both of those terms are increasing then
clearly it's increasing as a whole but
that's right I mean this is the bestest
this is the best option we might the
second prices user this is yes but for
different reasons I mean this you should
treat this just as a high level sort of
what we what some people have done in
the past is started from this idea that
you want some sort of corrected virtual
value to be increasing but then not
taught more closely about what that
corrected what you value is that's all
I'm trying to say okay and one final
advertisement roughly speaking one other
cool thing for somewhat cool thing that
I had to bring in is that the sellers
problem comes from a class of what are
apparently known that there's a thick
book in my desk are called mathematical
programs with equilibrium constraints so
you have standard constraints but then
there's also constraint that roughly the
distribution of buyers visiting you is
are visiting the other sellers is not
endogenous so it's not exogenous it's
endogenously determined it has to be
consistent with an equilibrium among the
buyers given the mechanisms that the
sellers have chosen okay these
equilibrium constraints are painful
because if you want to use your standard
first-order conditions kuhn tucker
optimal control panche again whatever
you like constraint qualification is not
satisfied so you don't have necessary
conditions anymore so instead I go deep
into Google and pull out necessary
conditions for optimality from the
literature of ampex and as i said
earlier in in progress is arguing that
the same conditions are sufficient but
that's very much in progress I have only
limited
alright so let's dive right in what's
the model and and model to sellers for
most of this talk to buyers values are
iid draws from a distribution on 01 bias
can visit only one seller the
announcement sellers are going to choose
mechanism everyone other than one of
them is committed to a second price
auction so it's really real timing is
lot of seller one chooses his mechanism
buyers choose which seller to visit
based upon the announcement and their
own valuations and one important caveat
is I'm just going to I am only looking
at symmetric equilibriums among the bias
so I'm not looking at equilibrium on the
buyers where the buyers biases choice of
which seller to visit depends on their
name okay only on yeah and then I just
look at truth-telling equilibrium at
each seller given the announced
mechanisms and the game ends i'ma wash
the virus and only visit one they can
only visit one mechanism yes it's just a
restriction I have no idea what would
happen if I didn't do that so at the
heart of his paper I mean his paper is
sort of you're right it's a complicated
dynamic model but at the heart of his
paper is the following simple question
which is take a large market and suppose
the outside options for this for the
other buyer all the buyers were given as
if there was everyone else in the market
it announced a second price auction and
that equity so he just pins down he
takes he pins down the outside options
as if we were in equilibrium then asks
the seller to optimize creating those
outside options is fixed assuming that
we're in a large market so I wouldn't
affect outside options so that I'm just
talking I mean I've maybe of
underrepresented Preston's paper but
this is sort of at the heart of his
paper
if I Preston didn't object to my and if
Preston objected Preston it let me know
the scripture all right so fixing
mechanisms of other sellers we can think
of this as seller ones problem as
announcing a direct revelation mechanism
and a visit rule so what's the Wizards
rule it's telling each telling I mean
it's big I'm basically doing mechanism
design so I get to choose the
equilibrium I like all I have to do is I
have to tell a buyer that if you're a
buyer of value V visit seller J with
this probability and and the constraints
well three constraints intuitively one
that the allocation rule is feasible so
a is an interim allocation rule it has
to be something that I can actually
promised to buy us that is i have only
one good for sale so I not need to make
sure that I can keep that promise too I
want incentive compatibility and three I
need this is the new set of constraints
that we haven't had to deal with an
optimal auction design which is that the
visit rules constitute an equilibrium
among buyers given the announced
mechanisms of the sellers so I can't
pick any visit rule I have to pick one
that's an equitable okay three helpful
observations first helpful observation
is one that is actually from Preston's
paper which is you might worry that we
have some complicated binomial or
Bernoulli random variable determining
the number of sellers at each number of
buyers at each seller but you can
actually make that simpler by just
saying that if you're not visiting the
seller just show up at that cellar and
report 0 okay so roughly speaking you're
still going to have you're going to have
a density at each seller that is the
original density of that value times the
probability with which she visits and a
whole ad on a huge atomic mass at 0 okay
and this makes life much easier and it
also makes Matt as much easier in the
sense that i'm just going to optimize
over this over achievable effective
distributions good the second I hadn't
invoked enough
famous auction theories yet so this is
the Matthews mask and Riley border
theorem there's already been two talks
on it but here's the rough question when
there are n buyers iid from a fixed
distribution what are the set of
feasible in turmeric allocation rules
well the set of feasible interim
allocation rules border finally clean
this up they had one direction basically
there's a set of linear inequalities
that define whether or not a interim
allocation rule is feasible and by
feasible I mean that there exists an ex
post allocation rule that alot only one
good at any given profile exposed and
results in exactly that interim
allocation rule and an aside that's
going to be useful is that this is a
convex set it's actually a polytope it
has a bunch of corner points and we know
what those corner points are those
corner points are effectively young
already introduced them but basically
they what border calls hierarchical
allocation rules so basically there's a
ordering on types and you give the good
to the buyer with the highest priority
according to that order the reason this
is going to be useful is because this
gives you a low-dimensional easy to
describe easy to work with way of
dealing with the set of all feasible
allocation rules okay so this is going
to span the set of bio strategies in a
helpful way and that's helpful because
of course the distributions are
endogenous so it doesn't help if you
just describe what the mechanism does at
different distributions in the internet
space is that a question or just sorry
now incentive compatibility is actually
the same as before so because I'm
pinning down I'm doing mechanism design
i'm picking the um I have to still have
that the mechanism is incentive
compatible for the industry distribution
of buyers that visits me in the
equilibrium that I'm asking buyers to
choose so in particular given that
seller one offers a mechanism with
interim probability of allocation a one
the pricing rule is going to be pinned
down in the standard way and the interim
surplus that of a buyer visiting the
seller is pinned down so these things
are pinned down in the way that they
always have been since everybody else is
running a second price auction and the
you know we have this notation for the
effective distribution we know what the
probability a buyer wins at seller J is
it's the effective distribution to the N
minus 1 this n minus 1 is exactly where
I need n equals 2 for some calculations
that are in progress because at N equals
2 this becomes 1 and therefore the
allocation probability is linear in the
wizard things without that it becomes a
messy polynomial that I have that I
don't know how to work with but that's
neither here nor there and by the same
argument the interim surplus of the
seller if she was to visit the other of
the buyer of value V if she was to visit
seller jay is given by SUV so now we can
just write this down we have this we
have this nice we have something that
looks and kind of close to the myosin
problem but there are a few changes so
this first I'm maximizing expected
revenue but it's no longer with respect
to a fixed distribution is with respect
to a distribution that's determined and
dodgin ously these constraints look the
same as before given the distribution
but I now have an additional constraint
on the distribution that is that if I'm
telling a buyer to visit a given seller
with positive probability
the surplus she gets that that seller
has to exceed the surplus she gets at
any other seller these additional
constraints are what make this problem
fun and of course you know we know what
all these terms are because of the
analysis we justed bad news still
there's still no maximum principle for
this class of problems I actually mailed
the person who thought they had it and
they said they still have some errors so
they're working through with it but what
they do have is a version for finite
problems so let's discretize let's
discretize the space of bio values what
do I mean by discretize the space of
value x values i'm just going to
consider values on a grid move the mass
of each move the mass of each interval
onto the lowest point on the grid and
consider the optimization problem for
the discrete problem instead so I now
have a standard finite dimensional
optimization problem firstly existence
holds the discretized problem has a
solution could probably use some fancy
topology and pull it out for the
continuous type but not done with that
yet and there's no point doing that
without a maximum principle anyway so
basically what's the idea we remember we
said we had this polytope that described
the feasible region you can think of
each mechanism as just a probability
distribution over all the corner points
so as a convex collection so this is a
finite so the finite set also the
feasible region is compact because it's
basically closed and bounded so you're
optimizing a continuous function on a
compact set which is great optimum
exists we can all go home happy
this is flashed for posterity these are
the conditions for a so these are the
novel conditions these are the
equilibrium conditions written as a
complementary slackness constraint the
necessary conditions for optimality
basically go ahead and ignore these
complimentary slackness constraints and
instead the multipliers on these proper
constraints are they don't have a sign
on them that's that's basically where as
you know standard Kuhn Tucker conditions
since these are proper constraints these
would be non-negative multipliers on
them so we've written a seller's the
sellers problem as an optimization
problem we've argued that it's
well-defined we have a maximum principle
well what's left we have to construct a
candidate optimal use the maximum
principle so let's go ahead and do the
first part very quickly it turns out
that you actually actually know what the
or what the equilibrium among buyers
looks like when two or multiple sellers
announce second price auction so let's
just quickly go through this thought
experiment I've announced a a reserve
price of one you've announced reserve
price of two what's going to happen
everyone below this well it doesn't
matter what they do everyone in this
interval obviously has to come to me
because they wouldn't even be served at
the event to you if you were just
slightly above this reserve price the
buyer if he showed up at the seller tues
mechanism he'd get basically no surplus
because even if he won which we'd win
with low probability he'd be paying
almost all his value in the form of the
reserve price so actually that's another
interval and the that whole area is
visited these guys visit seller one
uniquely what's important is that
there's a whole upper interval on which
the buyers are indifferent between these
sellers and they randomized 5050 okay so
that's that's the equilibrium shown by
version sakovich and peterson savaranoff
who both considered second competition
in second price auction for us what
relevant is that means that if you were
to announce second prior the other
seller was announcing a second price
auction with the reserve price of zero
and you announced some option second
price auction what they're telling you
is that there'd be some upper into
on which these individual rationality
constraints binded bound and this is the
embarrassing not embarrassing this is
just a part where I have no real
intuition to offer you which is you can
work out work through the system of
necessary conditions and can figure out
the multiplier corresponding to these
equilibrium constraints I have tried to
come up with a story that might justify
this and I have not so all I can tell
you for now until you can verify the
paper is trust me so trust now verify
later that's what I got and as it is for
M greater than two sellers it works out
similarly now I've shoved a bunch of
things under the carpet for the purposes
of a 30 minute talk which is the
discrete types have a slight degree of
freedom so the formal theorem is
actually even slightly weaker than I or
advertised which is suppose that the
distribution is such that this thing is
not non discrete decreasing then you've
got a fine enough discrete I then there
exists a fine enough discretization such
that announcing a second price auction
with any reserve is not optimal that is
second price options cannot the classic
second price auction none of them can
satisfy the necessary optimal optimality
conditions when competing against M
minus 1 sellers who have announced
second price auction with zero reserve
so it's basically that spiritually these
are the right necessary conditions but
that's life remaining steps our hope
that it works out in the other direction
lots of famous people have done lots of
great work in this area some people have
gone off straight to the large market if
you want to be really really grandiose
you can say that this problem is at
least as old as a Bertrand edgeworth
which dates back to the century or more
but it's really among a class of
questions that is just trying to end
organized both sort of how the goods are
assigned and how the goods are priced in
a competitive model and I'm not going to
with very limited time I'm not going to
hold you up from lunch any further so
conclusion I'd like to say that as less
work then one might hope given the
competition is all around as we hope
that we understand more about mechanism
design in the presence of competition
and the issues are basically that
there's issue it makes for very hairy
optimization problems and that we don't
always know how to solve these
optimization problems but there's light
at the end of the tunnel and I mean you
know you've seen talks by Brandon and
for those of you who've been around
you've seen talks by ever and vasilis
and so on that are trying to get it this
from a different that get at this from
different tools and from different sides
but basically even though these models
with competing markets and so on are
complicated to analyze they may lead to
simple options as the equilibrium result
which would be very satisfying
aesthetically so that's all I got to to
sellers to buyers is it a bit of a pair
of reserves such drama second prize to
reserve there is so that the reference
for that is Bochy and sakovich there is
no asymmetric pure strategy equilibrium
in second price options with reserves
even if the distribution that is not so
even if the distribution it's worse than
that so even if the distribution is as
nice as you like for instance the
distribution of x 0 values is uniform 01
you can't even analytically write down
what the mixed strategy equilibrium is
so not only is there no pure strategy
equilibrium there's no there's no nice
mixed strategy equilibrium to do other
economics with if it's yeah
have multiple cells in the same was not
an equilibrium unless you go literally
to the large market in which case McAfee
tells us it's zero and in which case you
can interpret the results of Peters and
seven of and others oh I should step
back for a second so you can interpret
those results of saying that it's sort
of an epsilon Nash to be sort of close
to zero one sort of class of results
that that I should have also been more
careful to suppose I moved to support
instead of over 0 1 i'm sort of really
thinking of a secon a c+ one support for
see large enough and for some
distributions then there might exist in
equilibrium and this is the paper by the
rug that I site on my previous slide so
this paper by gabor viraag who's at the
University of Toronto where he shows
that there is an equilibrium in pure
strategies among second price options
but both sellers charge a reserve price
below the lowest point in the support so
I'm sort of discounting giving a
discount aspires to compete them to show
up and that but yeah